earlier this week actor Mark Wahlberg
and his foundation along with a slew of
friends helped to raise funds for kids
via a celebrity golf tournament and I
was slicing along with them four
[Music]
so a few weeks ago I was asked to take
part as a golfer here at the Mark
Wahlberg foundation and Beaumont
Children's Hospital fundraiser here we
are at the Detroit Golf Club there's
only one problem I haven't touched a
golf club since I was 12 years old maybe
my pals can help
Jim Wahlberg runs the Mark Wahlberg
Youth Foundation tell me about the
Wahlberg Foundation where did this
originate and why the emphasis and focus
on you okay so first of all
thank you for coming out thank you for
willingness to participate
Raymond doesn't golf
and he still came out and and said I'll
do my Jerry Lewis thing I'll do whatever
I have to do to support and that that's
beautiful and I appreciate that I love
it
um so the Mark Wahlberg Youth Foundation
has been in existence for just about 20
years our family priest came to us and
said I got moved to a new Parish and go
roof is falling apart it's a centerpiece
in the community it's the only safe
place for kids to go in the evening will
you help me and so we raised the
necessary funds it's a matter of
responsibility you know if you are a
successful person whether you're a movie
star or a news anchor or you know a
construction one right right my family
my mother always made it a point to let
us know that there was always going to
be somebody that was struggling behind
us and we needed to do that all that we
could for them what's the one or two
things that need to be mindful of
hit the ball
a ball that's just sitting there all by
itself and and all of a sudden your
nerves you got to be composed you got to
be stable and for stability Sugar Ray
works the links the way he worked the
ring
[Music]
so I looked
just wait like with Tommy
I found a way to break you down it's
like yeah oh don't do that
don't do that
hello
[Music]
dessert no it doesn't hurt you know how
you're throwing puncher you're holding
your punches come on this has got to be
one of the great honors of my life being
with the Sugar Ray liner these Sugar Ray
well
I I feel more comfortable calling you
sugar too oh cause you
almost there but not there oh I'm sorry
I'm a sugar rate look I'm Nutra sweet
Ray compared to you let me let's be
honest watch that there this guy is
don't get in the way of those fish did
you did you realize I was gonna do that
no I didn't realize but I felt it please
warn me next time Ray warn me you got to
take care of yourself Evander Holyfield
offered me some slightly less traumatic
golfing advice the tip is for me is to
play with people who better because you
know and I like his children because the
best Bowl coach here so you plan as a
team
truly actor Kevin Dillon would give me
some golf tips your father was the golf
coach at Fordham yes he was yeah what
did he teach you he taught me mostly
about uh the mental aspect and he would
help me with my swing here yeah but it
was a focus on it was like keep your
cool you know I've been known to uh
throw a clavicate I don't do it anymore
don't do it today I can't do that at all
yeah I love throw no losing your anger
you gotta gotta keep your composure
God
I Mark that brings me here but he always
does great Charities and any charity
that he does I try and get involved if I
can
how you doing my friend I would only do
this for you okay
the tip yeah uh pick up tennis
if you haven't played for that long it
is very difficult to get the game going
tell me what this Foundation means to
you I know it started really as a call
from your local priest yeah well listen
we just want to give back to kids
growing up in similar situations it's
always been a focus on inner city kids
and at risk youth it'll be a sin and the
shame for us not to utilize the platform
to help in any way that we could whether
it's loading our time or finances I mean
we just we need to be going off well
when Jim called me I said I'll be happy
to be a gopher for Mark he said no no
golfer golfer I said okay well I could
actually use it I could have used some
help this morning organizing everybody
in all of our stuff I could have really
been in the system I'm gonna destroy the
group I think the great thing about it
is to know that when I play golf I can't
make money playing golf so I just go and
have a good time this spot and have fun
and keep it in perspective that's what
we're going to do and it's a great call
I really appreciate it thank you for
being it was a wonderful surprise
well okay every life and every game a
little Rain Must Fall so here we are
um about to get into the cart and hear
my teammates hey Mary and Chris and
Aaron and Abigail these poor people
their their score is going to be dropped
to levels unseen here but we'll have a
good time right absolutely we're gonna
have a good time all right we're on our
way greens beware
I have not played golf since I was 12
years old oh my goodness don't say it
with such sorrow pity I don't need your
pity Abigail just keep your knees bent
okay your head down yes and slow back
swing and slow follow but follow all the
way through yes okay all right we'll try
this I just bruised the green
this is not good send all the receipts
for the damaged Turf to Mark Wahlberg
Los Angeles California
90210 you have to hit the ball now
thank you thank you
I think I killed a resident of the rest
home next door
I was about that close to hitting the
window of that house
[Music]
I gotta say this is very good for the
ego the ego of the other people playing
[Music]
oh
[Music]
I have to say I think my favorite part
of this whole experience is riding
around in the cards
which I do love
I think I could do this all day
this is too big too that's not the
putter
where's the putter
this isn't a putter is it this it is
oh that's odd looking don't laugh Aaron
it's nothing funny about this
look at that beautiful seagull going by
damn it my question is how many more
holes do we have
it's a bank shot Mary stop laughing when
we were turning the card in a moment ago
you heard guys bragging I'm 10 under
we're 16 under well I'm six feet under
after this experience but honestly being
with Aaron and Chris Mary and Abigail
they taught me the foundations of golf
today which I'm very grateful for and
look to have done it for an incredible
cause for these children who will
benefit thanks to the Mark Wahlberg
Youth Foundation that makes it all
worthwhile oh all right give me the
clubs let's do it again look
there we go look Mary hello
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else